reste donc maintenant à attendre les
résultats et sur antenne 2 et europe 1
vous les entendrez dès 20h heure de la
fermeture des derniers bureaux de vote
heures de la première estimation c'est
deuxième but l'heure aussi du début de
la grande soirée élections que nous
présente pire bien oui daniel tout et
presse sur ce studio 4 qui est encore
presque vide ce matin mais croyez moi il
y aura du monde ce soir on a encore une
fois ce matin vérifier des centaines de
branchement les micros et les caméras
les lumières les téléphones les
téléscripteurs mêmes l'ordinateur bref
nous sommes fin prêts pour tous les
rendez vous que nous vous donnons ce
soir je voulais rappel ces rendez vous
17h55 jean pierre elkabbach et etienne
mougeotte prendront l'antenne pour vous
donner des indications sur le taux
d'abstention de 19 heures à 19 heures et
à 19h30 rappel de ces chiffres qui
seront affinées au fur et à mesure de la
soirée
19h55 début de cette longue soirée
réalisée par jean cazenave est organisé
par pierre henri arnstam et bruno dalles
dès 20 heures comme vous l'avez dit les
premiers pourcentages de voix
recueillies par chaque candidat ensuite
les analyses de politique de noël copain
alain duhamel gérard carreyrou daniel
brême et rené rémond à 21h et à 23
heures deux grands débats avec des
personnalités politiques
rendez vous donc en fin d'après midi
très exactement à 17h55 jean pierre
elkabbach et etienne mougeotte seront à
cette même table entourée et des 120
journalistes et techniciens des deux
rédactions d'antenne 2 et d'europe 1 et
puis donc je vous le rappelle dès 20
heures les premières estimations grâce à
l'ordinateur de ses deuxièmes
je viens d'apprendre que pire alain
avait un jumeau et demain matin de 7h à
9h patricia charnolé et moi même nous
vous présenterons une émission spéciale
consacrée aux résultats définitifs de ce
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec les spécialistes de
la rédaction mais aussi des informations
a déjà remis rigaud la participation
exceptionnelle de thierry le luron
émission préparée pas jean-pierre guerre
beaucoup d'entre vous et pour moi aussi
d'ailleurs la précision les estimations
fournies par l'ordinateur une seconde à
peine après la fermeture du dernier
bureau de vote reste un mystère et bien
laurent broomhead lève pour nous à un
coin de ce mystère
tout commence ici dans le centre de
calcul parisien de la c2 une nouvelle
bulle 16 opératrice reçoivent par
téléphone les résultats de 250 bureaux
de vote répartis sur tout le territoire
français au contraire d'un sondage
fondée sur des intentions de vote ici
l'ordinateur est utilisé de véritable
vote pour faire ses calculs au total les
250 bureaux sont représentatifs de toute
la france mais seule une partie de ces
votes seront connus à 20h l'astuce
mathématiques consistera s'en contente
force-là l'ordinateur bateau paraît
bureau de vote par bureau de vote le
scrutin de cette année avec celui des
dernières élections en 1979 pour chaque
candidat le cerveau électronique va
tenter de mettre en évidence une
tendance à la hausse ou à la baisse
dans les studios de la télévision au
cognac jay gérard grumberg analysera les
résultats
avec quel soin cision de la lave et le
résultat en moyenne 0 5%
sur à condition que à un moment ou à
destination la prestation soit
représentatif nous ayons à peu près
toutes les régions qui se paraient
attend
les premières estimations sortiront sur
les imprimantes entre 19h et 19h30 ainsi
donc les informaticiens seront les
premiers à connaître le verdict des
urnes mais ils ne vous le révéleront pas
avant la fermeture des derniers bureaux
de vote 1 20 heures et cela sur les
écrans d'antenne 2
il y en a tant